Alexander Cote and Shafi el-sheikh
belonged to one of Isis most notorious
killing gangs these monsters were
members of the murderers death cult the
crucified people buried women and
children alive use them as suicide
bombers burned men and caterers and
proudly hacked people's heads off in
full view of the world yet the
government's been criticized for not
demanding these savages won't face
execution if they're tried in the u.s.
look I don't want to see the death
penalty back here but I do believe in
rare cases there is a moral
justification for it and this is one of
those cases these two men who aren't
even British citizens anymore are
executed in the u.s. I believe it will
actually save lives they won't be able
to kill and torture innocent people and
there won't be around to incite or
command others to do it which is exactly
what would happen if they were in prison
here so yes let America have them
because it's an affront to British
taxpayers if they are asked to pay
millions to keep these monsters safe in
prison and if they are executed I won't
shed any tears it's two less animals
hacking the heads of innocent people so
Carol I understand the emotions behind
this it really is something that all of
us feel that these people deserve every
form of justice thrown at them but I
think it's precisely for that reason at
times like this when we want to see
people suffer for for the crimes that
they've committed against innocence that
we should stop pausing them and take a
deep breath and just remember the
dangers in moments like this to
everybody else's civil liberties there
are a few instances where national
security and it usually is national
security are used as a thin end of the
wedge to eventually chip away at all of
our civil liberties and that's my main
concern
I think it happened with detention
without trial it happened as a result by
the way scheduled seven the terrorism
laws were then used to stop lauren
southern who's not a terrorist from
entering this country are now I disagree
with a lot of what she stands for but
she certainly shouldn't have been
stopped entirely
make my point I'm talking about the thin
end of the wedge being then used to
extend terrorism laws using national
security against all of our civil
liberties it happened with Lauren
southern detention without trial it
happened with the extradition to America
that was non reciprocal it was meant to
extradite terrorists to the States we
ended up with bankers with autism being
sent to America with data you know these
guys were part of my knowledge I don't
think you're listening to the panelist
into your part I'm saying that once we
once we allow this under the guise of
national security to apply to terrorists
it ends up being extended to other
people I've cited examples to you where
happening two things two things these
guys are not British citizens anymore
they are likely to be tried in America
they have the defendants not what's not
for us all about this all about but it
is about their words it's about Home
Secretary cooperating legally with the
United States of America and not
demanding only chose not to it's nothing
to do with them
the Home Secretary traditionally what do
you think happened here when we when we
legally cooperate with a country the
Home Secretary is usually obliged to
seek assurances that that cooperation
doesn't lead to execution now that that
assurance what I said that I do want the
death penalty brought back here I don't
but it would actually for these guys you
know the Polish that the policy exchange
think tank says it was a person the ps2
said they want to bring back the ancient
law of treason and actually apply it to
return of jihadis you know the the
former the guy who to review our Terrace
Lewis said returned he had his on the
biggest threat to this country why why
are we why do we care about these men I
don't care I don't I know you don't
what do you thank you thanks Rachel I
just want to say a couple of things
first of all if Sajid Javid thought this
was such an honorable thing to do
why did he do it in secrecy secondly do
you think that we also have to take into
consideration and I know you're gonna
like me saying this but I think part of
the reason that we are even agree
- this is because of brexit because
we're so scared of signing up to America
right now then we allow them to do
anything getting the video we've been
losing our principles this it did not
leave this is something that you need
decades old we have always seek to
sauron cies from the US so why now under
these circumstances are we doing
something else and the other thing just
to add to that is can I bring in a
statement from Amnesty International and
what they have to say this is from alan
Hogarth who's head of advocacy in
programs and he says while the alleged
crimes of Alexander Cote and Shafi
el-sheikh are appalling
the UK's principled opposition to the
cruelty of the death penalty isn't
something it should compromise capital
punishment is the ultimate denial of
life it is always cruel and unnecessary
it doesn't deter crime and it means that
rehabilitation is not an option one I
think he's wrong because I think there
are some crimes so heinous that but I
want to read you I want to show you a
grab actually from the to G Hadees that
we're actually talking about just look
at the arrogance of these two guys here
watch them don't think that the death
penalty is on the table because of the
places where it's been said we would
face trial it's not reasonable that they
will give the death penalty in those
circumstances it's very reasonable
expectation that it could happen in the
United States is there any delay but I'm
not really worried if that if people
were actually adhering to their
principles such as someone's not your
thien until proven with evidence I have
no fear you know these guys have the
nerve to talk about not reasonable you
know I know you guys are talking about a
principle and a moral here but not all
murders of the same these guys didn't
commit a crime against a person or a few
people there were crimes against
humanity there was this set out to
destroy the Western civilization in the
most
excuses for what they've done it's about
who we are as a nation so should we just
have a quick look because for me why why
we we've not brought them here
is because you know such Sajid Javid has
no belief that actually if they came
back here they would face a proper trial
they wouldn't be prosecuted so if we
just look at this there is 425 Isis
members that have returned to the UK
approximately 50 of those of being
convicted of any crime and to me this is
the real travesty because as you just
heard that guy there say he's saying
well it is evidence and I'm found guilty
then whatever he knows and everybody
knows that if he was brought back to the
UK he wouldn't be prosecuted does rest
on evidence though so with those
returnees I think the issue is that is
there the evidence to prosecute them in
the case whether these two we we have
been cooperating with the Americans
gathering this evidence and at the point
I was making is I think all of us agree
that these two have committed some evil
evil deeds the issue is not about them
it's about what it's doing to us how do
we deal with principled morality let
America do with a we're not what an
absence of doing something in terms of
what we used to used to do Carol there
are sins of commission there are sins of
omission and in this instance we are we
are in danger of committing a sin of
omission we're not actually hear from
the mother of one of the victims Diane
Foley and she's she casts an interesting
light on this which is that actually
hanging is execution is in a way too
good for them it will serve their own
purposes I've become a what they will
become martyrs and they will therefore
radicalized others let's hear from down
phony mother of James Foley I think that
that would just make them martyrs in
their twisted ideology I would like them
held accountable by being sent to prison
for the rest of their lives Jim was
always one that wanted everyone to have
the benefit of the doubt
Jim was always one who wanted justice in
the fairest sense I think that you know
we descend to their level if we turn if
we turn the trial and punishment of even
jihadi terrorists into an eye for an eye
this is not who we are how could you
or anyone ever dissent to their level
and if you are talking about relatives
that David Haines who was SS laundry one
okay we want us all know descent into a
bob battery David Haines who was a green
Utah of the world
his daughter Bethany said I hope they
die a long slow painful death we have to
listen to what those relatives say
because they're the wanted support a the
victims are the people that are
important to you justice system is
important to you because she said
something quite interesting yes ever
watch what she says I put it to
ministers they cannot be a little bit in
favor of death penalty either we offer
consistent or position or we don't
so I just want to say that having
studied Islamist ideology and jihadist
theory in detail I can assure you that
not that this affects 100% of how we
think about it but they certainly Isis
and other jihadists do want us to
abandon our principles they want to
eliminate what they call the gray zone
and they want us to retreat and become
more more medieval in how we deal with
them Dianne also mentioned which America
lies more peace she mentioned about a
breach of Human Rights to me I am
there's no gray area you either respect
human rights are you done and if you
don't respect human rights and you'll
kill torture behead you just you you
lose it you negate your right to have
your human rights respected and I want
to just pick up on your point June
because I agree and disagree with you I
strongly disagree with you that this has
got anything to do with brexit and I'm
astonished that we are frightened stand
up to the gun facade but I do find it
quite interesting that this was done in
secret I do think I don't think it
demonstrates a policy change but I do
think well why was it done in quiet
because they know it's wrong that's what
everyone would vote but shouldn't have
legal representation because you know
they're murdered you know just friendly
with cases of jihad II so we know have
killed thousands of people maybe not
I didn't think we should have went
through justice should apply why do you
think that's funny you're laughing in
the face of people
yes you are and when Diana bird says
your Co binary you I'm not dying it's
the slip when she says you won't be a
little bit to say there are different
kinds of motors we're not going on any
slippery slope we've just given America
some evidence to help convict these guys
that's all we've done get the same
extradition we're not executing anybody
it's their concern sorry we're not going
to agree are we we're not going